[موسيقى]
وقفتنا الاخباريه الثانيه مع مراسله صباح
العربيه هذه المره من لندن معروف بعد
الاحتفال التاريخي كيف اصبحت شوارع
بريطانيا هولندا تحديدا بعد انتهاء مظاهر
الاحتفالات واجواء التتويج عرب اليوم غير
والله
صباح الخير عادل وصباح الخير راويه يعني
بالفعل هو ثلاثه ايام من التتويج انتهت
بشكل رسمي
انتهت بشكل رسمي يعني بدءا من يوم السبت
التي كانت يعني فيها مراسم تتويج مهيبه في
هذا الشارع بالتحديد الذي اقف فيه هذا
الشارع شاهد مسيرتين للملك تشارلز والملكه
حتى كنيسه وست
[موسيقى]
نعم هو مغلق لان يعني العديد من وسائل
الاعلام ما زالت كما نحن يعني الان ما
زالت
يعني
تغطي هذا الحدث حتى بعد انتهاء وذلك من
اجل رصد ردود الفعل على مراسم التتويج
يعني هناك طبعا العديد من ردود الفعل سواء
كانت الايجابيه او السلبيه حديث بين الناس
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ابداها مثلا
بالصوره التي يعني هذه الصوره التي نشرها
الملك تشارلز وهي واحده من مجموعه من
الصور التي نشرت من قبل قصر بوكينج وذلك
مع رساله قال فيها الملك تشارلز شكرا لكل
من شارك في مراسم الاحتفال من اليوم الاول
واليوم الثاني الذي كان هو يعني طبعا يوم
احتفالي بامتياز
كان شارك فيه العديد من الفنانين من مختلف
انحاء العالم ويوم امس ايضا الذي كان هو
يعني
او اليوم التطوعي الذي ايضا شارك فيه
الكثير من الناس في يعني في اعمال تطوعيه
في الشوارع حتى في منازلهم وحتى في مختلف
مختلف انحاء المملكه
يعني المملكه المتحده هناك طبعا العديد
كان من الحديث او التعليقات على مراسم
مراسم التتويج بانها كانت يعني جميله
دقيقه بمواعيدها حتى ازياء التي
يعني ارتدتها افراد العائله المالكه سواء
من الرداء الذي ارتدته كيتمد الذي كان
عليه الكثير من الزخاريف الحروب تدل مثلا
على كل منطقه من المملكه المتحده حبيت
اسالك سؤال شخصي شوي اكثر او عن مشاعرك
الشخصيه كيف كنت حاسه وانت عم بتغطي هذا
حدث مهيب يمكن ما نرجع نشوفه احنا يعني رح
نرجع نشوفه بس قصدي انه يعني انتظرنا فتره
طويله من عام 53 لغايه الان عبين ما كان
في تتويج اخر العمر
بالنسبه الي يعني اكيد موضوع موضوع تاريخي
وانا جديده يعني بعدني على البلد ولكن
بالنسبه للكثير من البريطانيين طبعا هم لم
يشهدوا مثل هذا الاحتفال مثل ما ذكرتي منذ
عام 1953 عندما توجت الملكه اليزابيث ولكن
يعني كان هناك نوع من هذه المراسم او
المراسم الملكيه شاهدناها العام الماضي
خلال احتفالات اليوبيرا البلاتيني الذي
كنا ايضا قد قضيناه
للقناه وكانت كمان ايضا جزء من يعني نشهد
على مثل هذه الاجواء الاحتفاليه
التاريخيه طبعا ايضا كانت مراسم تشييع
الملكه اليزابيث فيها نوع من المراسم
التشريعه المهيبه ايضا
يعني باجوائها بالطبع بالنسبه للكثير من
البريطانيين خلال عامين شاهدوا الكثير من
المناسبات الملكيه ولكن هذه المناسبه
بالتحديد قد تكون هي يعني الاكثر
يعني الاكثر
تفضيلا عند البريطانيين بسبب ان يعني
العرش البريطاني هو جزء من هويتهم الوطنيه
كان هناك كثير من الشعور بالفخر طبعا
والوطنيه رايناها بين الكثير الله يعطيك
الصحه والعافيه ويمد بعمرك لين تشوفين
تتويج ما بعد تتويج لويس يعني تتويج لويس
الصغير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات